let's just bring you some breaking news
now Manchester City are routine the
Premier League title Skies Fraser Ward
is in Manchester with an update on the
big game for Manchester City
um and Fraser excitement is an
understatement for the team
absolutely for the team and for the fans
it's very quiet here at Manchester
City's Etihad Stadium at the moment it
certainly won't be quiet here tomorrow
when they entertain Chelsea and when
they will be crowned Premier League
champions for the fifth time in six
years the only time they've missed out
was in that covert affected 19
2019-2020 season which Liverpool managed
to win quite so spectacularly with an
incredible Point tour so Pep Guardiola
has done it again I would like to say
that they've dominated all season but
strangely they haven't it has been a
they have been a very dominant Force
there on an incredible unbeaten run at
the moment but for much of the Season
Arsenal we're in pole position that due
to Manchester City missing a number of
games due to various other uh European
and so on uh commitments but also in the
driving seat for quite some time uh
during this season and uh Man City have
managed to to pull it back Pep Guardiola
going down in history is one of the most
successful managers here in Manchester
it's all got somewhere to go before he
matches up to so Ferguson but on the way
to doing that they are still on course
for the treble this season they've got
to face Manchester United they're on the
third of June in the FA Cup Final to
seal that one they're also in the
Champions League final it's a
spectacular four-nil win over Real
Madrid earlier in the week saw them into
the Champions League final that's on the
10th of June and that will be uh in
order to to achieve an incredible treble
but in terms of the Premier League
Arsenal slipping up at Nottingham Forest
they were only going to prevent the
inevitable if they didn't but for
Manchester City the celebrations will
start this for the premier league title
their fifth in six seasons